hey everybody welcome to the third and
final episode of grapefruit since this
is the last episode of the series I'll
be doing mostly finishing touches around
the roller coaster which means I'll be
working on some lockers as well as a
snack shop around the area
as well as some general foliage and
paths work and minor things around the
coaster itself and before I get into all
of that I'll be getting to what is
probably my recent addiction in planet
coaster that is making custom lampposts
I know it all sounds kind of lame but I
think there's actually some pretty
interesting stuff around all of these
topics since I'm really drifting away
from what I usually do since are usually
really two thematic episodes and very
densely themed areas but all of this is
very generic experimentation with very
minor things in planet coaster but
things that I think still have quite an
impact so without further ado let's get
into it so the first thing I'm getting
into is some of these custom lampposts I
wanted to have some modern lights that I
could use around the park that aren't
the in-game lights I still think there's
quite a lack of lights objects in the
game there are a lot of things that you
can attach the buildings but there isn't
really much that you can turn into or
that you can use as actual lampposts to
yourself now I think this is partly
because frontier has probably seen that
many people are just making their own
lampposts which is also really fun so
yeah I'm just working on my own lamppost
here for a lack of anything better in
the game but I sort of have an idea that
the lack of anything better in the game
is because you can make your own
lampposts not sure which came first
though in any case I wanted to start off
with a very simple generic lamppost with
a modern lights on top of it with a
wooden post underneath it it's something
that's quite simple actually probably
one of the favorite that have one of my
favorites personally since it it really
has a modern lights sort of look to it I
don't know which exact ones but I know
that a lot of the lampposts around the
Netherlands our Phillip Phillips
lampposts
and this one sort of reminds me of some
but I'm not quite good enough to
actually know the name but I'm already
really glad that I managed to make
something which sort of reminds me of
actual real life modern lampposts
because in the very heavily themed world
of planet coaster building something
that's very generic and common can
sometimes actually be one of the hardest
things to do now along with that I did
also want to switch up my lighting as
much as I can and the same goes for
these fences I know I always say this
but I don't think it really hurts to
repeat it anyway I think it's always
best to have as much variety as you can
with the sort of path elements so you
can see for the fences and this is a
very common thing that I'll do I have
all sorts of different fences and paths
borders around the area but along with
that I also have all sorts of different
lights and lampposts around the area as
well which is partly because it looked
good and partly also because it's just
fun to make more so here I go again
making another very simple lampposts
this one isn't actually made out of
lights objects but just a simple 3d art
sphere shape but I think it actually
kind of works as a simple limp and
there's also a trick that I'm using here
which I greatly recommend using even if
you're not even building your own
lampposts and that is to not have any
lights in your lamp itself and then
place the lights using a colorable area
lights underneath it which is what I've
done in this case the lamp itself is
actually just a 3d art piece so the
colorable area lights which actually
emits light above the ground if you
slightly put it on the ground is what
actually gives off the lighter you can
see I'm doing the same thing for all of
the other lamppost as well since they
don't really give off as much light
either and I think that the big
advantage of this is that you actually
have control over the way that your
light looks for a lot of the in-game
lights it's easy enough to place a light
and just have lights around that but you
don't have full control over how that
light looks exactly how much it spreads
out what the
it is how bright it is and by using
lights like this I think you can
actually get some slightly better
looking lights and have some slightly
more control over where the light goes
so yeah I like to place lights that
aren't actually functional but then just
put the colorable arian lights in there
I'm doing a similar thing for the
spotlights of the rollercoaster here I
wanted to light up the entire coaster
track so that actually looks fanciest
night at night as well but the
spotlights don't have enough reach to
light up the entire track so what I'm
doing instead is actually hiding some
very large floodlights underneath the
ground that actually line up the coaster
and then putting in the areas where I've
placed those large lights putting some
spotlights that sort of make it look as
if the lights is coming from those
spotlights but in reality for some of
the higher up parts it's actually coming
from a light that you can't see although
in some cases the spotlights are
actually what you see which is mostly
for the parts that are close to the
ground so it's some of that very basic
lighting done I'll definitely get back
to lighting later on in the episode I
wanted to head back into something else
which I've been planning for quite a
while and that is to have a building
with lockers in it it's again a very
simple addition and not really one that
is fitting inside any theme or anything
like that but something that I wanted to
try just for setting the scene for the
roller-coaster if you will the idea
behind this is that at least the
surroundings of the coaster sort of look
as though the coaster would be placed in
a real-life theme park but obviously I'm
not building an entire theme park around
grapefruits so I just want to give as
much of the surroundings as I can to
sort of give the impression that you're
actually out there in a generic theme
park in a sort of Cedar Fair or Six
Flags Park probably more drifting toward
a Six Flags park
to do so give some of these basic little
constructions and scenery items that you
have around coasters in parks like that
and one of those things is to have
looker areas which I've heard although
as European I I definitely can tell from
firsthand experience it's been getting
quite popular to force people to use
lockers in your area and make those
lockers paid lockers as well which is
pretty douchey but in this case I'm just
putting it in here multi capitalize on
my guests but just to finish off the
area in a pretty neat way I had to
experiment a little bit more with
another generic style which I like to
call the warehouse style this thing just
looks like a warehouse and there's just
gonna be a warehouses around this area
everything is made out of metal and
other pretty cheap and undecorated
materials there's nothing really themed
about this this is just providing
services and nothing else really
although there is a little bit of
platform
the thing that I did with the pants work
which is quite interesting in which I
think is really great if it weren't for
the fact that it takes so much time is
just to lay out the path work the way I
wanted it using these building pieces to
be very very concise these are windows
so all of this this big plain path area
that you see is all upside down windows
and using these to actually shape down
the layout of the path and once it's all
set up and I've got the planters in
place and all of the buildings I'm
actually gonna put some four meter pots
through these areas in such a way that
you can actually have planters in the
middle of your paths and all kind of
things and actually shape your paths the
exact way that you want to while at the
same time making sure that you can also
shape the path that the guests are gonna
take through that area so we don't have
any guests walking through trees or
anything like that there are just a
couple of simple 4 meter paths that are
gonna sit underneath all of these
windows
now on to the thing that this entire
building should probably be about the
lockers I don't want to really take
credits for making this locker design
because I sort of just looked at the bro
coaster lookers and figured I could copy
that so yeah these Hertz just sort of
look redesigned that the bro coaster
guys came up with it was actually my
idea to take the the warning stripes the
the black and yellow stripes and turn
those into lockers I never really
imagined that would be possible since
they're very large pieces but by putting
those black bars in between them using
art pieces you can actually make it look
as though they are small squares and the
nice thing about those bars is they have
a really grainy metal texture to them
which is perfect for these sort of
industrial lockers that I've got going
here I'm not sure if it would work for
every theme park but in this sort of
warehouse slightly industrial but very
generic sort of design I'm going for
with these buildings I think it fits
pretty well so on to the next building
we're getting into a small snack shop
which really only just sells fries but
it's here to make this entire area a
little bit more attractive because I do
realize this is just one big collection
of warehouses and concrete so hopefully
by adding one shop over here we can at
least make it look a little bit better
also it's extremely crowded but this
building as well isn't really going to
be anything special aside from some very
simple decorations that's gonna make it
look like a shop where you can buy
things it's not really decorated
whatsoever which does have as a bit of
an advantage that it doesn't take too
much time to make it now over here I'm
heading into a small planter that I
wanted to put in here just so we don't
have an entire concrete's empty area
over here since that would just really
break up the look of the park so at
least there's something going on I will
also put some trees here in there in
this area because otherwise it would be
very still and
looking although still we've got a lot
of concrete paths and a lot of very
simple generic industrial buildings
one of the major inspirations for this
actually that I haven't mentioned so far
but that really comes back a lot
throughout this build is Apocalypse The
Last Stand which is a Bingham stand-up
coaster that has this sort of industrial
theme and even though you know you'll
find traces of this sort of way of
building in many Cedar Fair and Six
Flags parks
I think it's that build which I look to
mostly and grabbed a lot of inspiration
from in how to actually approach these
sort of things because to be very fair I
have barely any experience building like
this and I'm usually not really a fan of
this I just like experimenting with
different sort of styles and things
which is the main reason why I'm getting
to it now but I'm really quite
unexperienced when it comes to this sort
of way of building coasters so yeah if I
stall of ideas from that I'm sorry
that's just something that for me it was
very inspiring to see because I I can't
really see builds like this in real life
myself so yeah here I'm putting in the
paths and you can see that people are
using it and I think it works out quite
well like it looks as though the entire
gray area is really just parked but you
can make the people walk in ways that
are logical and in ways that they don't
walk through anything else
so I'm actually quite a fan of making
parts this way I might experiment a
little bit more with that in the future
it's not exactly a new method or
anything like that but just a simple way
to sort of make you plotting a little
bit more I guess so no it's not a new
way in anything because people have been
doing this sort of thing for a while but
on the scale of taking an entire path
and putting the real paths underneath it
I think that's something which could be
done quite a lot more if only you
weren't so very time consuming now at
this point in the build getting into
another warehouse build which is not
quite as interesting as the locker-room
building
or the snack shop it's just something I
wanted to add in here to make the little
row of facades over here a little bit
more symmetrical and well rounded so I
think this is probably a pretty good
time to talk updates a little bit
because I sort of need to apologize for
how long it's taken me to get this up
and for how terrible this is made my
upload rates recently and after this
video my upload rate is actually going
to spike quite a bit so recently I've
been to Germany two times over the
course of two weeks to travel around and
do some theme parks which was really
awesome visited phantasialand
movie park toverland for a bit as well
as Heide Park council Park Binta Hamburg
visited a fair around the I'm not sure
what the entire area well it's the Ruhr
area and it's in a town called Khurana
which barely even exist anymore it's
kind of just still exists to support the
fair that's grown way out of proportion
and one awesome thing about it is that I
had Olympia looping but yeah that
happened so I could make videos at the
time but also I've had a cold and the
one time that I sort of still hadn't
like gone into my call too badly that I
could still record I recorded a
commentary for this episode over a week
ago and due to some weird obesity issues
the audio kept skipping so I can use
that and hence here we are more than a
week later and I've just come out of
water polo practice and my nose has
opened up a little bit well enough that
I can speak through it and sort of get
this episode out in a decent manner I
hope so yeah things have been delayed
massively because of all that sort of
stuff happening but still I've been able
to build things and do things in planets
goes through so there's gonna be quite a
bunch of new videos popping up in the
future the very near future see how
that's a little bit of a general life
updates sorry for how long it's been
taking me to get this out and for how
bad my upload rates has been the past
few weeks hopefully we'll get back to a
somewhat decent manner even though I'm
moving to Japan on the 31st of August so
we'll see how that's gonna go just in
case you're wondering I am at the moment
looking around for buying a laptop and
I've sort of already settled my stuff on
getting a very small and portable sort
of setup that I can hopefully still
record videos in Japan
so that stuff should still be going on
I'm looking into it in any case so yeah
back to the video this is the warehouse
and it's really just a warehouse like I
said there's nothing about its only
thing that's special about this building
is that I put the door in the wrong
place there's the door on the front of
the building here but obviously nothing
can get in over here it should have been
at the back while you could actually
write something into it or anything with
it because you're not gonna be able to
really use this door on the front only
thing is it's kind of a faux door
because it's just there to make the
building look a little bit less boring
and so in true low budget park fashion
I'm also trying to find my way around
some way that I can make this warehouse
an entire build look a little bit more
inviting what at the same time just
completely shutting off the very boring
and alienating aspects from the view of
the public so what I'm doing here is
just putting a wooden fence in front of
the building and after that I just put
some chairs and umbrellas in there so
that at least it looks a little bit a
little bit more inviting than an empty
facade the same kind of goes for the the
other buildings because they would look
a lot worse without all of the
advertising the banners of the signs
some of the trees that I had just
sneaked in flown with those buildings
because trees always make buildings look
better if you put them next to it unless
your building is actually good on its
own in that case don't put trees right
in front of it but um yeah in this case
it helps to wash out the boringness and
the industrial called alienating
concrete surfaces everywhere so yeah
hopefully these few umbrellas and tables
make everything look a little bit more
cozy
and it really is it's a pretty cheap but
easy way to make something look a little
bit more theme-park esque and inviting
to people and this is where the real
filling in the gaps starts since at this
point I'm really done with most of the
important things that had to be done
around the park so I'm starting to do
more of the foliage around here just
quickly filling it up in a way that sort
of looks like it's been all newly built
I'm not actually sure if I went into
this very much but the entire look of
the area I wanted to build it in such a
way that it looks as though grapefruit
is a relatively new coaster and also
that it's a relatively low budget
coaster so everything is done quite
simply and you'll notice that a lot of
the foliage is very young and hasn't
really got the time to grow yet the
entire area around the coaster itself is
barren and all of the all of the bushes
and foliage are still sort of awkwardly
in that soil sand combination just very
small and still have to grow out of that
so yeah everything looks very new which
I think it's it's it's one sort of
interesting way to approach things one
thing that I've always noticed a lot and
this doesn't just go for a planet
coaster but it's it's always gone for a
roller coaster tycoon 3 as well as that
people tend to build a finished products
in in the game and just sort of see it
as that whereas in real life you do sort
of see that rights transform over time
that they're never one thing they're
very different from the time when
they're built to when they're many years
into being up and running so most
coasters especially if they're really
landscaping around it's in the first
year the kind of awkward and new and
everything sort of barren around them
I found this actually especially around
Baron 1898 in the efteling sorry about
the bad pun but it looks very different
in its first year compared to how it
looks now and right now should be its
third year I think and what you're very
often find is that people are sort of
building finished coasters
but not really this sort of just new
coasters where everything still has to
grow and sort of get used to being in
that sort of get used to the entire
configuration there's there's something
about new coasters that just makes them
very different to how they are when
they've been running for a while
sometimes parks will also opt to add
more scenery along the way so in the
first year courses are very theming
'less or they sort of changed the way
that they operated based on the first
few days but yeah stuff changes and in
planet coaster very often the courses
sort of senior sis static thing that you
know they're the way they are and
they're built a certain way but it they
sort of change over time sometimes which
i think is quite interesting also
something that I noticed is that very
rarely you'll see people actually build
coasters in the winter or you know have
dead trees around with no leaves that
sort of stuff unless they're actual
winter coasters in snow biomes but you
don't really see wintery coasters
without snow anyway
random thoughts I just wanted to get out
of the sort of standard
ruts and it get a little bit out of my
comfort zone but um I think we're
running into the end of this episode
with some of the Lost clutter then I'm
placing around the area with some random
items to spruce stuff up a little bit of
foliage at the end there and some final
path work but by now we should almost be
done and that should be the end for
grapefruits and that's pretty much
Bennett's for this little cheap weird up
bowl of a coaster that I've actually
really enjoyed I do have to say and I
really want to thank everybody who's
been watching this series as well I mean
seriously
I've gotten a lot of positive comments
about this series and at first I had a
little bit of apprehension apprehension
for starting a coaster which is very
different to what made you know my
channel popular in the first place so
thank you everybody for watching this
series thanks for all the feedback and
onto a good final video for grapefruit
which by this time is already done but
it should be coming out a little bit
later
but still in the near future see ya
thanks for watching guys and I hope to
see you guys in a final video and in the
next project
you